Coral reefs are some of
the most diverse places
on the planet.
But it's not easy being a
small fish on a big reef.
Tiny animals must
overcome
huge challenges to keep
their coral city alive.
For this production we
have wonderful gadgets
that we filmed with.
The closed circuit
rebreather
is revolutionary for
filming animal behavior.
All of the gas that
you're breathing
stays contained within
this one unit,
and you don't blow
bubbles anymore.
And the animals are just
so much more
comfortable around you
they're not scared off
with every single exhale
that you make.
It's just amazing how
much closer you can get
to all of the fish,
and how much
longer you can
stay down there.
Today we were
searching for
Peacock Mantis Shrimp.
Which are a colorful
animal that lives in a hole
that it builds itself
in a reef.
It looks amazing
on the probe.
You know being actually
below it
and like like looking
up at it.
It's just so encouraging
to find a really good animal,
and so encouraging to
start to see the visual.
These new scopes that
we're using on the series
Got a cool shot of it
coming out
like looking super
aggressive, and then...
Just broke my probe,
just like came out
and just,
smashed the front of it
Sometimes nature just
gives you a little...
We witnessed this
absolutely massive
Crown-of-thorns
outbreak.
But, these tiny little red
crabs live in
coral colonies and when
a Crown-of-thorns
puts its arm up over
the top of the coral
these tiny little crabs
they nip away at the
the tube feet and at the
spines of the
Crown-of-thorn.
The Crown-of-thorn
turns around
really quickly and starts
going the other way.
So, it was awesome
actually.
Just seeing these tiny
little crabs
defending their home,
their little coral colony,
it was amazing!
A diverse community
of tiny creatures,
all playing their part,
keeps coral reefs healthy
and far more resilient
to the many threats
they face.
Tiny World